WEEK SINCE MAY, LOSING ABOUT 1.5
POINTS.
PROTESTERS ARE FILLING THE
STREETS OF PUERTO RICO'S CAPITAL
RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE CONTINUING A
WEEK OF DEMONSTRATIONS DEMANDING
THE RESIGNATION OF THE GOVERNOR
THERE.
WHO IS EMBROILED IN A
SOCIAL MEDIA SCANDAL.
CORRESPONDENT JEFF CALL'S IN
SAN JUAN TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, JEFF.
>> GOOD EVENING, THERE ARE NO
SIGNS OF THESE PROTESTERS
SLOWING DOWN, THEY HAVE BEEN OUT
HERE ALL WEEK, TRYING TO GET AS
CLOSE AS THEY CAN TO THE
GOVERNOR'S HOUSE.
A SPIRITED GROUP THAT HAS BEEN
CHANTING, SINGING AND TAUNTING.
ALL UNDER THE UNIFIED MESSAGE
THAT THEY WANT HIM GONE.
THE PEOPLE HERE ARE NOT ONLY
UPSET OVER THE LEAKED CHAT
INVOLVING THE GOVERNOR AND
MEMBERS OF HIS CABINET, BUT A
GENERAL DISTRUST FOR ANYONE
INVOLVED IN THE ADMINISTRATION
TO MOVE THEM MOVING FORWARD.
>> THIS IS THE TIME TO FIGHT.
THIS IS THE TIME.
WE ARE A COUNTRY THAT IS READY
TO RISE UP.
WE WILL NOT ALLOW THIS.
>> THE GOVERNOR HAS BROKEN.
PEOPLE DO NOT BELIEVE IN HIM.
IF YOU HAD A DROP OF DIGNITY, HE
WOULD RESIGN.
>> THE GOVERNOR MEANWHILE ACTIVE
ON SOCIAL MEDIA, HE TWEETED OUT
PICTURES AT LEAST OF HIMSELF
SURROUNDED BY SOME OF HIS
CABINET MEMBERS, BUT MADE NO
MENTION TODAY OF THE ONGOING
PROTESTS OR ANY PLANS TO RESIGN.
BUT SOME DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES FOR 2020
ARE WEIGHING IN.
PEOPLE DO JUDGE, CASTRO,
BETO O'ROURKE, BERNIE SANDERS,
ELIZABETH WARREN, SOME OF THE
TWEETED OUT THEIR SUPPORT FOR
THESE PROTESTERS.
>> WE HAVE SEEN COMMENTS THAT HE
AND OTHERS IN THE ADMINISTRATION
HAVE MADE.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT USING FORCE
AGAINST THE PEOPLE OF
PUERTO RICO, THIS GOVERNOR CAN
NO LONGER BE EFFECTIVE, AND I
BELIEVE THAT HE SHOULD RESIGN.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ALSO TWEETING
ABOUT OR DO WE GO THE OTHER DAY.
HE SAID SOME BAD THINGS ARE
HAPPENING IN PUERTO RICO AND
THAT IT WAS FOOLISH FOR CONGRESS
TO GIVE $92 MILLION IN HURRICANE
RELIEF.
BUT ACCORDING TO FEDERAL DATA,
SO FAR THE U.S. CONGRESS HAS
SENT ABOUT 42.5 BILLION WITH
HURRICANE RELIEF.